when it comes to who identifies as LGBT
there's a generation divide in the u.s.
Yas Queen between three to four point
five percent of adults identify as LGBT
compared to about eight to nine percent
of teenagers the thinking is that
younger generations feel more
comfortable sharing their identity and
it's important that we get these
statistics right the old expression is
if you aren't counted you don't count
this is Kerith Conron from UCLA's
Williams Institute in talking with state
legislators and federal policy makers
the first question that people ask you
when you go into their office is how
many people live in my district and if
you can't answer that question it's very
hard for anybody to give your issue any
serious consideration and this is why
Kerith started doing this kind of
research because being counted and being
visible it really matters especially if
you want politicians or policy makers to
address issues important to your
community.
The US census which officially surveys the population has never
directly asked any questions about the
LGBT community but researchers have
developed an interesting workaround in
1990 the census added the term unmarried
partner as an option for households
mainly with straight couples in mind
this was to account for the growing
number of people living together outside
of marriage researchers began to
indirectly use this data to count
same-sex couples since the census also
asks the sex of each person in a
household so someone can look at that
combined information to see how many
same-sex partners live together in the
US but this indirect form of counting
can lead to mistakes it's much easier to
just ask people directly
so in 2020 an improvement was made to
the form and options include a same-sex
married partner a same-sex unmarried
partner an opposite-sex married partner
and opposite sex unmarried
partner but this doesn't mean that every
LGBT person is going to be counted the
new questions are only counting same-sex
couples who live together so if you're a
lesbian couple but not living together
you're not counted if you don't identify
as male or female
there's no way to note this in fact
Kerith estimates that the census
overlooks about 80 percent of people in
the LGBT community I think it would be
ideal if the US census surveys as would
include questions that ask people about
their current gender identity coupled
with questions that ask about assigned
sex at birth this is in addition to
questions that we ask people about their
sexual orientation identity since the
90s activists in the trans community
have pushed for ways to be identified on
surveys beyond the Census and by
increasing their visibility in survey
data they've gotten results so even
doing an analysis of NIH funding for
transgender research I've seen a major
increase in the number of grants funded
for transgender folks over the last 10
years this is huge with this funding
researchers can develop health care
specifically for the trans community
despite the shortcomings of the current
census Kerith believes that it will
eventually grow more and more inclusive
I am confident that there are many
people within federal government that
believe that inclusive data collection
is a priority and that data collection
will move forward